you know and I had a I had an eggplant
parmesan today that was truly
life-changing and I'm not getting money
from these people or anything I just
want to say a shout out to dominicos
specialty store you know an Italian
specialty store that Sal Vulcano on the
a'practice jokerz turned me on to and
Pulver Z among others great eggplant
parm is such a tough dish to make cuz
it's either too mushy like where it's
literally or the eggplant slices are cut
too thick but this was perfect like it
was absolutely perfect
and it comes frozen and you heat it up
in the oven or the microwave every time
there's a choice between the oven and
the microwave I just do microwave
because I did cocaine at 13 and when you
do cocaine at 13 you've grown up in a
home where you use the microwave a lot
so I am no stranger to the microwave I
don't care that it radiates your food
and it radiates you and I mean the only
reason I'm not dying of coronavirus
might be the fact that I stand in front
of the microwave and stare it in while
the little food goes around remember
when microwavable food was considered
like a healthy option yeah like people
would go and get literally a chunk of
frozen something that look like an
artifact that was found and then it
would melt and then become something
like they had Lean Cuisine had
sandwiches for a while where you would
literally like he was like add water and
then it would become a [ __ ] sandwich
and they had these you know they would
serve them in these little trays yeah
there they are
they served them in these little trays
crisping sleeves click crisping trays
and he would crisp up this and when you
were eating a Lean Cuisine sandwich and
that's what it really looks like right
down there that's what it really looks
like when you're eating that and I've
eaten that and you're in an office and
you're eating a lean
zyne sandwich like that and and Ben you
got to put that up on the podcast
because when you're eating something
like that man
there is no reason that you don't take
out a I mean whatever gun would blow
your head clear off 45 I'm something
where there wouldn't even be a chance
you'd live like it would have to just
take you out but I've seen it man I've
done it I've seen secretaries fat people
they're trying to get ahead trying to
get ahead of you know just choke down a
Lean Cuisine microwavable sandwich I
mean the horrors of mass-produced
diet food because before people before
there was this organic movement or
farm-to-table there were people that
were like the same what I love about
like this era of dieting they were like
the same people who [ __ ] us are gonna
help us now right like the same
companies that have done nothing but
push sludge down our throats through
drive-through windows are now going to
answer the call and provide us with
healthy alternatives that we just add
water and it's a steak just add water
and I watched my mother and countless
fat Long Island women go and then men as
well more shamefully though a man a man
pulling out a Lean Cuisine then there
was like an element where it almost got
weirdly masculine like if you had a Lean
Cuisine in the break room you had to
kind of be you had to peacock a little
and be a dick like girl [ __ ] leg was
it sort of [ __ ] what like if people be
like relax dude calm down you know but
that's that's what health food was for a
very long time was just genuine I mean
look at look at that I mean could you
imagine sitting now you don't really see
now I guess I haven't been in an office
environment in a long time
but I'm sure there are still people out
there choking down a Lean Cuisine
they're tough there's a little Asian
chicken one which is just four to five
morsels of a meat that the FDA has ruled
is close enough to chicken and then just
like a a little like a handful of angel
hair pasta and it just boils like it
cooks it gets so hot that when you when
there's no Lean Cuisine that you put in
your mouth where you don't burn your
mouth third-degree burn maybe that was
the strategy could all these people just
burn their mouths and they won't eat
because these linguas ian's get hotter
than anything I've ever seen in my life
I mean they get hotter than a cast-iron
pan because they're its just chemicals
have you ever lit plastic on fire that's
what this is that's what these things
are it's amazing